bodies weren't just left in the streets
as ukrainian troops and police
investigators go house to house they
find more victims in butcher charred
remains piled on top of each other
it's horrible
you see it's just
six bodies here
and uh
that house
uh you can see maybe a three and
their house it's maybe one body
it's shot they
was shot
and burned after eating
a whole town a suburb of kiev is now a
crime scene witnesses say russian troops
became stuck due to ukrainian resistance
and went on a killing spree
natalia alexandrova says russian
soldiers checked her nephew's phone
before taking him away his remains were
recently discovered
he was probably killed on the 8th of
march he was lying all this time in the
basement his body was found 4 days ago
and we buried him he was shot in the ear
pictures released by the ukrainian
military show what appears to be a
torture chamber in another basement
where people were handcuffed and shot
while on their knees
as residents return home confirmation
that multiple family members are gone
era gavriela found three bodies in her
yard one is her brother another her
husband
the scenes from butcher appear on
russian state television
viewers are told that ukrainian nazis
carried out the killings a provocation
by nato
these are fake atrocities which the
russian army was immediately accused of
and western media began to repeat the
accusations simultaneously and without a
break for sleep it's more about
self-psychological self-defense when uh
ordinary russians uh do protect
themselves uh from what
goes absolutely against their beliefs
and what should force them to think
about their own leadership as
war criminals
every gruesome discovery and newspaper
headline now used to feed the war
machine
the blame game aside there's now a real
fear that the scenes that we witnessed
in butcher will be repeated in other
cities across ukraine cities like
kharkiv chennai and mariopol imran khan
al jazeera keiv